bonsoir lit la fin des propos qui ont
bien sûr suscité beaucoup de réactions
oui effectivement une phrase du préfet
de police de paris qui a pris tout le
monde de court une phrase qui était
prononcée lors d'une opération de police
qui visait à empêcher les départs dans
le cadre des vacances de printemps qui
on le rappelle débute officiellement ce
samedi pour la zone ile-de-france alors
cette phrase du préfet de police de
paris a suscité l'indignation sur les
réseaux sociaux parmi lesquels des
réactions de responsables politiques
écoutent et la gravité de la crise que
nous vivons appel de la part des
autorités sang-froid discernement et
dignité
cela fait longtemps que monsieur
l'allemand a perdu les 3 il doit être
remplacé dans les plus brefs délais
après cette ultime provocation
ce préfet est une honte comment peut-il
culpabiliser tous les malades et les
centaines de milliers de salariés
continuent à bosser qui se sont
contaminées on leur dit que c'est leur
faute
la parallèle entre sanction et
infections
c'est non seulement au lieu mais en plus
complètement faux ce n'est pas possible
de laisser un préfet de police exprimé
ainsi les dégâts sur les proches des
familles déjà éprouvés sont
incommensurables et ceux qui travaillent
ce prêt fait la honte de la france
que fait-il des personnels soignants des
caissières des seniors n'est pas de ceux
qui sont allés voter
des pompiers des policiers des anonymes
respectueux des règles mais touché par
la maladie qu'ils se taisent et qu'il
dégage au delà des bornes il n'y a plus
de limites voire le préfet l'allemand
face grimaçante du régime
pour lui ceux qui sont malades qui sont
morts l'ont bien cherché
écoeurant l'état d'urgence sanitaire ne
doit pas avoir ce visage insultant les
gens doivent être respectés alors les
réelles des réactions du côté des
politiques mais aussi du côté des
médecins qui estiment que cette
corrélation très simple évoquée par le
préfet de police de paris ne repose
finalement sur aucun élément
scientifique et puis l'entourage du
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il s'appelle
salaires a lui aussi reconnu que ce
propos du préfet de police étaient
inexactes alors face à toutes ces
réactions
didier lallement
est revenu sur sur sa déclaration et il
a dit qu'il regrettait ce qu'il avait
dit écoutez ce matin lors d'une
opération de contrôle des départs en
vacances
j'ai tenu des propos laissant entendre
que les malades d'aujourd'hui en
réanimation étaient ceux qui hier ne
respectait pas le confinement sur le
fond cela est faux mais au delà de
l'inexactitude c'est une erreur et je la
regrette
à plusieurs titres d'abord parce que je
sais avoir heurté de nombreuses
personnes qui ont des proches en
réanimation à l'hôpital ou qui ont perdu
récemment un des leurs nul ne devrait se
sentir coupables de vivre une telle
situation
un tel drame et je n'avais pas
l'intention de rajouter la culpabilité à
leur peine ensuite parce que j'ai pu
donner le sentiment que je n'étais pas
pleinement conscients du fait que nombre
de nos concitoyens ont été ou sont
encore exposés à cette maladie en raison
de leur engagement professionnel alors
que sans eux notre pays serait à l'arrêt
alors actuellement dans l'hexagone plus
de 6000 patients infectés par le
coronavirus sont en réanimation une
parmi elles il y à aussi bien
effectivement des personnes
indisciplinées mais aussi des personnes
qui n'ont pas le choix ou qui sont en
ligne de mire un qui sont au front pour
lutter contre la propagation de ce virus
aussi bien du personnel soignant que des
livreurs ou encore des gens qui
travaillent dans le domaine alimentaire
et ces personnes là n'ont pas le choix
elles sont obligées de sortir de chez
elle elle ne pose pas donc respecter les
règles
de confinement merci beaucoup lille a
falli l'afa amouzou donc en direct de
son lieu de confinement évidemment merci
beaucoup lit la fin